what you're trying to do in training is
you're trying to get people to think
trying to get people to think on their
own and that is the most beautiful thing
that you want as a leaders you want all
your people thinking and you want them
to be able to think with a completely
open minded mind that's been completely
freed from constraints and the way that
you do that one of the ways that you do
that one of the methodologies you can
use to do that is everybody's got their
box right that they're stuck in so you
formulate a problem that the only way
that they're going to solve the problem
is to get outside of that box and you
know one of the one of the best ones is
you put somebody in a situation where
you put parameters on them and you say
hey no matter what you're not allowed to
go across this line hmm and then you put
in a situation would have to cross that
line and the only way they're gonna win
us across that line and then they come
back and they said well you did told me
not to cross that line you know what I
didn't tell you get you all your guys
killed or I didn't tell you to to not
make that investment even in this
critical situation or I didn't tell you
not to do that if we had an ecological
disaster that was going on right so you
need to train people to use common sense
mm-hmm that's what you want to train me
to do and it's very hard you'd be
surprised at how at how constrained
people's brains get mine yours everybody
we get stuck and so it's great to do
drilling and training where you are
actually opening up the mind and freeing
the mind from any kind of constraint
where you can see things from varied
perspectives that are different from
your own and you can see outlets and
solutions that you would never have seen
if you trap yourself inside your box and
those are the kind of training scenarios
that are outstanding and those the kind
of training scenarios that make people
better leaders and better decision
makers because the key thing that they
learn how to do is they learn how to
detach even at that moment we talk about
it all the time but if you can't detach
from that situation you can't detach far
enough away from the picture to see that
the only way you're going to solve this
problem is by going across that line
that you were told not to go across if
you can't make that detachment you're
never
across that line you're never going to
open your mind you're never going to see
that solution and that is a horrible
trap to be stuck in